oui pendant un mois
mois d'août je présume n'ont pas encore
quand les prendre et vous un bon mois de
janvier importe comment et pourquoi des
vacances d'hiver
oui on me la force de mon travail non
j'en reviens à peu près huit jours
quinze jours où étiez-vous en italie
côté de la mer tyrrhénienne papa du côté
de l'adriatique
pourquoi être allé à l'étranger oh ben
ça c'était pour moi cette image de notre
des circonstances atténuantes en
justement ce temps que je pars pour mai
toujours quel moyen de transport utilisé
vous en vacances on peut je pris la
voiture
comment allez vous partir en voiture fm
en voiture est ce pour vous le moyen de
transport le plus agréable c'est à dire
lui qui pratique mais certainement par
exemple dans quelles régions dans le sud
de la france et peut être éventuellement
en espagne au jeu concerne l'endettement
pourquoi en espagne
je n'ai jamais eu l'occasion d'y aller
certainement que cette année si j'y vais
avoir l'occasion et
j'aimerais simplement ma formation dans
le midi sans doute pourquoi dans le vide
ce que j'aime bien la mer par quels
moyens allez vous partir en espagne en
voiture ambitieux selon jouaient ce
moyen de transport idéal la voiture oui
ça permet une certaine autonomie de
déplacement qui est très agréable
évidemment les routes sont encombrées
mais enfin le trail
ne pas se promener ensuite les moyens de
transport idéal pour les vacances
personnellement oui je le crois pas ce
qu'on peut sans doute je trouve que l'on
peut aller n'importe où où vous s'étant
déplacés se déplacer comme on veut quand
on veut surtout ça qui est inconstant
vacances pratique disons oui pour faire
le voyage pour descendre dans le midi
mais sur la côte fait ça à pied quoi je
n'aimerais pas partir en vacances non
parce que je trouve que je m'en vais
très souvent été parfait vous êtes un
homme heureux
merci
excusez-moi d'interrompre votre sieste
mesdemoiselles et vous en vacances pour
l'instant naturellement depuis longtemps
le pin's mais est-ce que vous pratiquez
toujours le camping la première fois 1
alors quelles sont vos impressions de
pionnier c'est assez sympathique ça
défend différentes continue ici ses
premières est-ce que vous pratiquez
toujours des vacances de cette année de
tout l'est toujours de cette manière
pourtant j'ai une voiture une voiture
congo ne s'est pas fait mais je ne veux
pas m'en servir passé on a trop chaud
dedans et de l'inde
et quand je me réveille le matin je suis
gelé et drake une tente à double hour je
suis pas jeune et parfois pour vous
madame comment avez vous organisé votre
vie ici sur ce terrain avec mon français
c'est assez agréable seule masse qui y
est je trouve cet inconvénient pas
seulement poussé qui reste mais pour
surtout pour ceux qui restent trop
longtemps par exemple un ou deux mois
parce que les cantines il n'est pas
gardé la nuit ce qui est intéressant
mais justement c'est que le voisin
change souvent
oui vous avez tous les jours n'est ce
pas une autre figure devant vous je peux
alors c'est immédiatement c'est très
amical bonjour monsieur d'où venez-vous
ne sais pas où allez-vous etc
ou est-ce que vous passez vos vacances
ici ou ailleurs pensez vous que ce soit
la meilleure formule de vacances en tout
cas la caravane je peux ensuite parce
qu'on n'est pas obligé d'être toujours
bien habillé ceux qui parce que je tout
vacances ces pousses détendent pour
trouver ça que vous n'êtes pas au tout
au long de l'année à lui si on est
obligé se tenir sur ses frontières comme
disent que les français cité j'ai appris
tout hasard
ben c'est pas des vacances parce que on
se détend pas et on en gros si fatigué
ou travail comme les parties ont ils du
repos avant tout de la distraction
relax tout à fait relaxe etes-vous des
intellectuels fatigués pas tout à fait
en effet peut-être mais
fatigue et non ceux qui a un état
d'esprit peut-être fait ce qu elle va
paraître tout le monde ça c'est logique
mais justement on peut s'épanouir pour
deux jeunes filles vous n'êtes pas trop
sollicité